>> What are the chances of India really being
the next superpower?
Well, I mean obviously they're very good.
When you've got over a billion people, you're
going to be taken very
seriously, whether in terms of trade, resources,
agricultural demand,
the views that India has in international
negotiations.
I guess the main variables will be how well
India succeeds with its
three E's: Expansion, yes.
That's definitely in the cards, a lot of growth.
Getting rid of your exclusion, and trying
to do it promote inclusion
and that folds into a whole number of areas
like fixing water problems,
because the poor often don't have water, like
fixing housing, fixing
access to employment which India is trying
to do very hard with the
NRGE and I think is doing very well.
So expansion, exclusion and excellence.
And one of the major themes of this meeting
has been the real need for
better education, more accessible to people
and producing better
product.
So yes, India will be a superpower.
How important, how really much of the determinant
flair, how able to
take advantage of its own strengths, will
depend on well it sticks to
the -- to the determination to achieve these
goals.